welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down one of the big things
about the brand new Final Marvel's
trailer she tore a hole in
space there's a different
reality leading into
ours heavy spoilers ahead and I want to
talk about a major thing that's going to
be happening in the movie this is
covering all of rumors going around
about the post credit scenes and how the
X-Men could be brought into the MCU you
don't want to know you know where to go
go go to Ryan AR you know I was going to
slag him off but he's actually a nice
guy anyway with that other the way
thanks for clicking this and psych shut
the up Ryan Ary okay so according to the
leaks around the movie we'll culminate
with DAR Ben constantly opening up
portal through using the other bangle
that we saw Miz Marvel getting in her
show this will be to replenish resources
for Hala after it was completely
destroyed due to Carol killing the
Supreme intell Ence the over usage of
the bangle will then cause an incursion
to happen which involves two worlds
colliding into each other this was
something it was a major part of the
buildup to Secret Wars with Jonathan
Hickman's run discussing how best to
handle these Universe destroying events
an incursion involves two worlds being
pulled towards each other and if they
Collide it wipes out Both Worlds the
Illuminati started secretly destroying
worlds heading to the 616 and in the end
this sdle things down to Just Two Worlds
remaining that was them and the Ultimate
Universe which is whatever event she
tuck us into Secret Wars now according
to the rumors that came out for the
screening of the Marvels a couple of
months ago we'll see one of these being
caused in the Final Act we'll then watch
Monica go and fix it from the other side
which is when she'll be stuck in this
alternate reality Monica will then wake
up in a hospital bed where she'll be
greeted by a couple of familiar faces
the first of these will be her mother
who we saw became Captain Marvel when
she was in the 838 I'm not sure if this
is that universe but it could definitely
be due to another character that pops up
that is none other than Kelsey grammar's
Beast who's now fully CGI instead of a
costume in outfit now according to the
rumors he was placed in the last minute
because Marvel have realized they need
to get to the X-Men fast tickets for the
Marvels have been selling like cold
cakes and so far it's the lowest
pre-sale tickets for an MCU movie this
side of coid so what they've done is
show their tying things together and are
playing things as cross as fast as they
can to hit Deadpool 3 as I said these
are still rumors with us getting the
info from across a lot of different
sources the scene originally just had
Monica and Maria meeting up and this was
what was shown at a screening back in
June you have to remember Monica never
got to say goodbye to her mother and
thus they're having this moment to kind
of be like the character gets to say
goodbye however they then realize that
they had to move things up mt's more
X-Men in the universe to get people back
on board now Mt is actually going to be
seeing this movie tonight so if this
video is deleted then you know what
happened now I'll leave it up even if
it's wrong but we'll have a clearer idea
over the next couple of days about what
what's going to be popping up now from
what I've heard if this is the 838 then
this is still going to be the members of
the Illuminati Maria will have survived
her encounter with Wonder and in the
aftermath of it she'll have then
reformed the group with other members if
you've ever read Jonathan Hickman's run
then you'll also know that a similar
thing happened during that Beast ended
up joining the Illuminati and here it's
likely in the wake of Professor X's
death the Illuminati was actually formed
to represent each aspect of humanity so
every single side had their own
representative for example had Xavier
for the X-Men and black B to stand in
for the Inhumans Neyo was the ruler of
Atlantis and Doctor Strange was the head
of magic so Beast stepping in makes a
lot of sense as he's up there as one of
the most intelligent mutants on the
planet now going forward from what I've
been told they're going to sort of be
bringing all these timelines together in
Deadpool 3 we'll apparently see things
picking up from the Days of Future Past
ending where we watch Logan returned to
the present yet he saw that the school
was still fine and that Beast himself
was working as a teacher this will then
all head towards Deadpool 3 where we'll
watch as they bring more of the X-Men in
last year you might remember that we
talked about what the overall plan for
Secret Wars was and how it talked about
sort of doing a soft reboot this is
something lots of sources backed up
since and I think that'll be used as a
way to bring X-Men into the main
timeline if you've read The Secret Wars
comics I'm sure you'll be familiar with
this and you'll also know they did
something similar with Miles Morales
miles was off over in the Ultimate
Universe but this event streamlined
everything and brought him into the main
one now what I think's going to happen
is that we'll see this other world where
the X-Men were always a thing and that
their history will be filled in during
an upcoming show that is of course going
to be X-Men 97 which we know is getting
worked on for Disney Plus in that we
have Professor Rex in his yellow chair
which we also saw popping up during
Multiverse of Madness that two used
notes from the X-men theme so I'm
guessing that they're going to just be
pulling all that across they could then
fill us in on everything we need to know
and that could act as filling in the
timeline at the end of days the Future
Past
this could also be used as a way to show
how the Illuminati is set up and then
take us directly into the events of
Multiverse of Madness one thing I've
always been confused about with Marvel
is the whole Prejudice thing that's
surrounding the mutants after all we
have so many people with superpowers in
the Marvel Universe yet there's one
group who are hated on because of it I
know there's reasons because they're
mutants but I really don't think that
would matter when you have other people
running around with similar abilities
anyway a way I think this could cause an
issue is by the fact that they come from
an the world if the universes are indeed
streamlined then we may see the X-Men
being brought into the 616 there could
then be this prejudice against these
people because technically they aren
part this world now Beast also kind of
shows the direction that they're going
and how they're pulling in a lot of the
Legacy actors from what I've heard fi
plans to bring in the old the cast and
then once the MCU does its soft reboot
have other actors coming in on top of
this the other post credit scene
supposed to involve M Marvel who tracks
down Cape Bishop throughout the film
Fury will have a device and this
basically gives him profiles on all the
soups this is something that we saw him
using during secret Invasion and at one
point Cala will apparently get her hands
on it using this she'll then track down
some of Heroes which is what will take
at a cape Bishop it's here that she'll
then come face to face with her and
they'll apparently also bring up Cassie
Lang this obviously helps to set up the
Young Avengers which is something that
we've had teased for a long time these
two credit scenes are extremely
important for the mcu's future with them
not only further ushering in the X-Men
but also setting up this group honestly
I kind of wish they'd stop making the
post credit scenes the most hyped up
things about these movies cuz I'd have
loved to have seen these story lines
actually integrated into the plot I know
that the Marvels is having a difficult
time marketing this and you can see why
they went as teaser heavy as they have
in that brand new trailer will it be
enough well we saw Superman couldn't
help save Black Adam and I kind of think
it's just a sign of the time that
people's tastes have changed now I think
the X-Men coming back is a big thing for
Marvel as they're probably the Studio's
most popular group well well they were
before the Avengers hit their high point
but definitely in comics before the MCU
dominated movies either way I'd love to
hear your thoughts and if you weren't
interested in seeing this film has this
final push got you on board comment
below and let me know and make sure you
subscribe for videos like this every day
please drop a like on the video and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button you get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
going to get some heavy spoilers merch
we've also got our t-shirt line located
below the video that will let you pick
up all kinds of tops like our Theory
time one house of dragon stuff ly te's
and a lot more we drop new designs on
there all the time too so definitely
keep an eye out for them and thanks for
all your support now if you want
something else to watch we've got a
video on screen right now talking about
all the shots we haven't seen yet in
lowy season 2 this is pretty much
breaking down what we think will happen
in the finale so if you're interested in
that then please head over there but out
the way huge thank you for second
through the video I've been Paul and I
see you next time take care
peace